we got the Velvet memo okay it's winter
I can I can do this now you look sharp
it's a big night for you it is all about
you my friend congratulations on this
amazing about to give me a panic attack
but thank you for that yeah what does
this recognition mean to you you're no
stranger to having people sing your
Praises
um well never in a concentrate a dose
like this this is pretty intense this is
uh uh you know a room filled with a
lifetime of peers and collaborate
collaborators and people that I I Adore
and some some of which I consider family
so it's this is amazing this is a moment
a pinch pinchview moment for sure are
you nervous for anybody to hit the
microphone tonight while they present to
you oh my God I'm sure I'm going to be
roasted uh that I know I have no idea by
whom and by in what way but that's
coming last question for you another
Honor on the way for you is of course
dad of four four under 10 years old how
excited are you and Blake I'm we're very
excited you know we'd have have to be
you know you'd have to be a [ __ ] to do
this four times if you didn't like it
um yeah yeah it's going to be a nuts uh
but we're very excited now do the girls
understand there's going to be a new kid
on the Block oh yeah they're in they
love it yeah they're ready thank you
Ryan
[Music]